[Music]
what do you make for like a profit
margin or something like that it's about
85 profit margin you still can operate
with an 85 profit margin correct because
that's just not a big market for it well
there's there's not it's a it's
definitely a niche service but you got
to think too it's it's also something
that a lot of people don't want to do
which means that you can charge a
premium for it why isn't a lot of people
not want to do it is it just because
it's disgusting disgusting and nasty
yeah
all right guys bang bang I thought a
great place to start this conversation
would be the economics of a crime scene
which sounds absolutely absurd but
literally your business you guys go in
after a crime has occurred after the
police have done all their work you got
to clean it up someone's got to do this
uh but it's a business you're an
entrepreneur how should we think about
what the actual economics of the crime
scene are like when you guys get the
phone call and you're like there's a
murder or a crime an X address what
happens yeah I mean the uh the easy ones
are somebody died in the bed decompose
that's pretty easy cut and dry the
harder ones are you know Granny died on
the third floor and melted through the
second floor and is dripping into
somebody else's bathroom on the second
floor how does that happen that's
because she was just left unattended
yeah left there for a while nobody
checked on her so she just decomposed
and we've literally had a melt through
floors before so that's you know a big
big crime scene
and we're using the term crime scene but
is it always a crime or could it
actually just be natural death or or uh
is it yeah I kind of use that term as an
umbrella really um it most of the
cleanups that we do I would say are
unattended deaths okay and you get
called to come do one of these cleanups
uh do you go with a clipboard and you
check out the scene and then you call
back and you're like okay here's what we
need do you guys show up like a cleaning
truck like how do you arrive on scene so
every truck is outfitted to clean up any
type of biohazard scene okay anytime so
you're ready to go we have a two-hour
response time we're there we're ready no
matter what so
um
that is advantageous obviously because
it's a sense of urgency for people and
how do you think about pricing right
like uh it's not exactly I'm going to
the grocery store and I got like a price
tag on on the product it's not Amazon I
don't think people are going on clicking
some buttons uh when they call do they
try to describe to you what this scene
is and you just quote them a price is it
a monopoly where like they pretty much
call you and you just send them a bill
for whatever you think it's worth later
how does that work it's a little bit of
all the above okay so there's no uh like
you said uh kind of market for this type
of thing so what we do is um
we try to be we're not the most
expensive but we're also nowhere near
the the cheapest
um so what we do is we utilize software
to kind of tell us based on the
different markets that we're in what the
average going rate is for a particular
labor or replacing subfloor you know
personal protective equipment there's a
line item for literally everything so
um I really never quote over the phone I
always kind of go to the scene because
there's so many things that you can't
see especially someone that's calling on
the phone you know they're like I looked
at it for two seconds I don't want to be
in there I it's on the floor and I'll
even say what kind of floor is it and
they'll go I don't remember like they're
so kind of traumatized by it that I'll
say oh listen I'll just come by and take
a look at it and it takes me kind of two
seconds to say
yep it went through the drywall or you
know it's once you've been doing it how
many times are you getting called by
like a family or a relative a friend
something like that versus like you're
getting called by the government whether
it's law enforcement or or somebody like
that I would say 99 by the family by the
family yeah maybe one percent but okay
so most of the clients are actually like
private clients they're not actually the
government right correct and when you
get on scene uh what are you doing is
this like somebody comes to clean your
apartment or your house and like they
kind of show up they got some supplies
they you know work their way around or
is there something that uh has to take
into account the actual you know there's
a dead body uh yes what do you do so the
body is typically always removed
um there's been maybe less than 10 cases
where I got there quick enough to where
the body was still there
um and those are just kind of wow you
know kind of takes you back especially
when it's like a shotgun suicide or
something there's just Parts everywhere
um so you're just essentially you're
doing the opposite of what like a Molly
Maid would do a Molly Maid you know if
they they were in this room they'd
probably start vacuuming from there and
vacuum their way out we're cleaning from
the door in so we're not
cross-contaminating exactly exactly so
you know you're you're literally just
going item by item and the attention to
detail is so precise on it so it's not
like oh my God I forgot to you know dust
the lamp it it doesn't work that way
it's like hey you left a tooth behind
you know so it's kind of catastrophic to
make a mistake like that you want to be
extremely thorough what do you do with
the materials after you get done
cleaning up like let for example uh
there's a tooth or there is you know
other things that have been left behind
what do you do they get bagged red
bagged and then they get autoclaved
which is it kind of looks like a
submarine but it's uh essentially a
giant microwave it Heats it up to about
330 degrees somewhere around there uh
some of them
will have a shredder attached to them
some don't so it just gets essentially
heated so that we're the point of any
disease would be dead non-viruses and
then it just goes into a normal landfill
Believe It or Not wow yeah all right how
much do you charge for this
so it varies for job but it in general
it's probably about seven to eight
hundred dollars an hour okay and what do
you make from like a profit margin or
something like that it's about 85 profit
margin so even though you have physical
labor you have cleaning supplies you
have uh you know Vehicles you have all
these different things that most people
would associate with a kind of a small
business in the real world kind of the
atoms not bits world you still can
operate with an 85 profit margin correct
because there's just not a big market
for it well there's there's not it's a
it's definitely a niche service but you
got to think too it's it's also
something that that a lot of people
don't want to do which means that you
can charge a premium for it and why
didn't a lot of people not want to do it
is it just because it's disgusting
disgusting and nasty yeah I mean it's
disgusting I I think it the physical
fitness required uh for it is uh really
the primary thing why we lose employees
maybe they they just can't physically
handle it most people think oh they must
be just emotionally wrecked by it and
actually that's never been an issue it's
always been the physical you're wearing
personal protective equipment a full
respirator it feels like you're
breathing out of a straw sometimes
you're in attics cleaning up people's
brains you're working with power tools
it's just a very uncomfortable sweaty
hot nasty environment
why are you working with power tools uh
we're cutting up subfloors we're cutting
drywall uh sometimes we're cutting beds
and you know just a bunch of different
things apart anything that's been
contaminated has to go so really not
only are you guys cleaning you actually
are deconstructing things oh absolutely
right if if they've been contaminated
right do you also participate in like
what I would consider more like General
Contracting work of like rebuilding we
subcontract that out okay to somebody
else yeah all right how big is your
business uh we did about 12 million last
year we'll do about between 16 and 18
million this year and where do you get
customers from are they just Googling uh
yeah essentially you get you get a lot
from online presence we've got a lot of
national contracts
um you got to think that you know
Property Management
thousand two thousand people Under One
Roof essentially a lot of stuff happens
in apartments a lot of stuff happens in
hotels so you know we kind of try to
Target our marketing to the bigger
vendors the B2B and when you do let's
call it 16 to 18 million dollars how
much of that is in one single Market
versus it's actually you know nationally
across uh evenly split these days yeah
that's spread out over 33 markets okay
yeah and you have full-time employees in
each one of those markets or you're
Contracting out and we have franchises
in each location okay yeah and how do
you pick those franchisees not very well
interesting okay that's uh yeah that's a
science that I would definitely say I've
Not mastered it's it's a difficult thing
to pick
the right franchisee for a particular
brand what is the uh uh worst case
scenario that you've had with a
franchisee
we would need another podcast to go over
we have a long time in the world
um
we've had I mean we've had them lie
cheat steal pretty much across the board
um we've had one that just kind of
that a lot of a lot of them have this uh
notion that they they buy into a
franchise and they're just going to sit
on the couch and wait for the phone to
ring and that's not the case at all like
the the point is it's it's business in a
box but you still have to work like we
don't go down there for you so you know
we've had
um evasion of royalties where they'll uh
try to take cash on the side
um they'll uh God it's it's just endless
we've we had one that failed out and
became a prostitute
um that's an interesting yeah very
interesting you know uh how did you
figure that out uh she told somebody she
told somebody the business isn't working
I'm now a problem she can't she can't
run a business so she's just gonna
sell our ass essentially interesting
yeah was she successful with that I
don't know yeah I I don't get royalties
from that part yeah
also I guess you kind of only have to
manage yourself yeah exactly yeah I mean
maybe it's an easier that's a higher
profit margin I would assume yeah that
is uh interesting how does the uh
franchise work what do they have to pay
to buy a franchise and how do you
structure the royalties so it's it's uh
pretty inexpensive considering you know
franchises as a whole it's about let
it's less than 160 000 they pay eight
percent royalties and a three percent
National brand fund it's not that bad no
not at all yeah I mean what what do you
think the national average for
franchises is probably like 300 to five
well I mean you've got the high-end like
McDonald's it's three three four million
just to get in and you don't even own
the land
um
and then you've got home-based type
businesses that are less than 50 Grand
so you know it's really I don't I
wouldn't know what the kind of the
average is yeah so you guys will do 160.
how much of that is via own and operated
uh you know locations I guess or like
cities versus the franchises they're all
uh franchise operated they're all
franchise operated okay uh what has been
good about the franchise strategy
it gave us the ability to so one of let
me back up a little bit so one of the
biggest issues when I first started the
business all the way back in 2005 was
everyone said the same thing we didn't
know anybody did this we thought the
police did it so I thought the police
did exactly until you sat down in that
chair exactly why was a police officer
prior to that and I didn't even know who
did it so what does that tell you so I
knew I had a huge hurdle to overcome so
by us franchising and kind of spreading
our Geographic you know abilities there
we're able to reach more people so that
they don't have to do this themselves
because that's what people were doing
previously yeah either that or you know
uh hiring unqualified people to do it
and maybe just not getting it all and
then wondering what that smell is you
know two months later that's crazy yeah
that's sad so how did how did you start
so I was in law enforcement for seven
years and uh or something else yeah I
did beat I did Undercover narcotics
undercover prostitution
and uh what's that like which part both
the narcotics and the prostitution the
prostitution was fun narcotics not so
much why was it fun uh I'm just gonna
screwed with guys and try to lure them
into a situation well you I mean that's
the part that was it was like shooting
fish in a barrel you didn't have to lure
anything here I mean it was like are you
like how does it work like you're just
gonna stand on the street no yeah so
there's a couple different types of
stings uh the particular one that I did
was Street
um where you're literally we would go
into an area that was known for heavy
prostitution we would kick out the real
prostitutes make them go to a different
area and then we would take their place
essentially and if you guys know that
it's known for prostitution people in
the area know it's for prostitution and
I swear to God I mean within 30 minutes
it looked like a Chick-fil-A line they
were just lined up there was uh probably
two of us on one corner two of us on the
other corner and they could hardly keep
up with arresting all of them like it
was that way it was insane and so what
the guys pull up was the conversation
um they would say um how much for a blow
job oh they were just straight up asked
like there's no code language they're
getting right to the right to the point
yeah right to the point and and then you
back then it was cheap oh like how much
20 bucks for a [__]
I don't know who we should be judging
more on that side of the market yeah
exactly okay for a [__] yep then does
the officer get in the car no no that's
the key you never get in the car okay
why well I mean you're a Sitting Duck if
you get in the car because there's
security concerns right so I say hey
I'll meet you around the corner
I don't want anybody to see me getting
in your car
and then they would go around the corner
and a 300 pound Burly man would meet him
and all of a sudden the twenty dollars
doesn't matter anymore exactly got it
and uh what are the types of people that
are doing you know this was shocking to
me okay because I was 23 at the time I I
watched a lot of cops okay so I was 23 I
was very naive okay and I thought
you thought it was like drug addicts and
stuff that's what I thought I thought
this was just gonna be oh my God was I
wrong White Collar total white collar
yeah every once in a while you'll get
the roofer or something on their way
home
um we got an FBI agent on duty in his
fbiv oh come on I swear to God hold on
on his lunch break on his lunch break
this during the day
during the day you are doing a
prostitution sting as a beat police
officer undercover and an FBI agent on
duty in his car on his lunch break
pulled up and tried to get a [__] oh
no he went around the world so he knew
he'd done it before
and he was in his 60s
yeah what is that conversation like once
he gets arrested
he looked like someone had shot his
mother like he he literally got out of
the car pulled out his badge
and he just like put his head down and
he knew his life was over yeah that was
it and his life was over because he
loses his full retirement he he gets
fired he's probably divorced and you
name it his whole life is over over a
forty dollar Bang
literally on his lunch break that's just
what I call good judgment yeah something
like that all right what about the
narcotics things
just so you know I break down the
economics of a lot of stuff on the show
I've never broken down the economics of
prostitutions well you know we can talk
about the profit margins because they're
excellent okay explain
um well I mean you know twenty dollars
for a blow job what takes five minutes
so do the math
five minutes if if if he's any good
anyway so the narcotics is a bit
different because uh I worked in uh
Kansas City's worst neighborhoods so
being Caucasian was actually a big
disadvantage uh for me so we were buying
a majority of crack cocaine
um a little bit of weed and meth so but
crack by far was was the drug of choice
and you're in your uh young 20s you said
doing this yeah I was 20 five okay and
is it strategic that they're using you
because you're a woman because you're
young a combination because you're white
like well the prostitution was very
strategic it's because I'm a woman so
they would essentially go to all female
officers and say who's interested in
overtime and I'm like hey I'm a glutton
for punishment I'll [__] try it so um
but I I didn't realize how much work it
would be like you would think you know
hey I'm standing on the corner this is
easy you know but it was like a [__]
Chick-fil-A line like but it was insane
when you say it's a lot of work is that
because you then have to go back and do
all the police reports no I didn't have
to do any of that it was a lot of work
because of the volume so literally
you're trying to make a deal with a guy
and have him go around the corner and
you're seeing the next guy that's coming
up and trying not to [__] yourself
because he's going around the corner and
you're supposed to be following you know
what I'm saying so it's it's very
strategic on how you're making this deal
but you're also
undercover you're you're not letting
them know because I didn't never did the
busting there was guys waiting for them
when they went around the corner yep and
then around the corner basically you was
a SWAT team yeah and you don't want the
people in line exactly you got it so
yeah you almost have to like slow your
roll a little bit a little bit so we I
was with another female officer and we
would kind of play off of each other
like I would lean into one car she would
lean into the other and then we would
you know send them to a different
country do you have a gun with you yeah
no gun no wire Yeah so basically you're
kind of out on your own oh yeah it
basically there's another officer there
but neither one of you oh they're around
the corner you have other options
I mean yeah you're wearing
you know and that's another kind of
misnomer that oh you're supposed to
dress all sexy and stuff we dress like
we were [__] homeless really oh yeah
like oversized clothes
um I put black out on my teeth it's a um
it looks like nail polish but it's black
okay when you put it on your teeth it
looks like you have no tooth in that
particular area because it's yeah so the
more gross you look the more that they
believe that you weren't a cop
that was
yeah because they would they would
always say this is another big misnomer
so for everybody that's looking for
prostitutes out there I'm helping you
out hey hey boys listen up all right
listen up I'm helping you out so they
would always go if I ask you if you're a
cop you have to tell me right and I'm
like yeah I'm not a cop that's a biggest
number ever you could say whatever the
[__] you want yeah I don't know where
they're getting that from well probably
because they watched TV or TV or stayed
at a Hampton Magnum PI or some [__] I
don't know but that's not true and so
you could just say whatever you wanted
yeah I could say I'm a [__] rocket
scientist yeah how do you think about
um what do they call it uh entrapment
like I used to watch like uh I remember
uh I would watch Cops and they would
always have this one thing it was like
in Boston I don't know why if they
thought idiots were in Boston or what
was going on you know hey Boston yeah
yeah but uh they would put uh a bicycle
out on the sidewalk and they wouldn't
chain it up and they would be up like in
a you know office building or a hotel or
whatever and they had a little
binoculars on within 20 seconds someone
goes by grab some bicycle jumps on hops
off and then they go in there and they'd
get them right uh and it was like again
Chick-fil-A line like literally just do
all day long oh yeah all day long uh and
people would always be like that's
entrapment it's not okay what like where
is the uh like what is entrapment and
what is an interesting so what I had to
do was I just had to get them to agree
to a sexual act for a monetary value and
it didn't have to be cash one guy
offered me a Whopper
I'm like you broke [__] okay whatever
it's a Whopper he still gets arrested
yep so it's any type of negotiation that
sex for monetary value yep so when they
come up and they say hey you want to
party well that could be taken in any
way and I'll say sure what do you want
okay well what do you do like they're
trying to dance around it and I'll say
blowjob's 20. [__] 40. yep and then
they'll go all right I'll take the
[__] bam there you go got it so you
can even offer oh I can say whatever but
they have to agree yeah yeah and it's
like this weird thing right where uh
there is the monetary value and I guess
like they didn't actually commit the ACT
but they committed the negotiation
that's it it's just gonna go yeah
because I'm not getting in the car yeah
yeah but but like that's the whole thing
right it's like I guess also there's
probably people I'm thinking of like the
hardcore uh libertarian audience would
argue like they didn't actually do it
yeah I can see your point right and so
like the way the law is written is it's
the agreement of the negotiation yeah
but you know after doing this for
several years I'm like why the [__] are
we doing this this is just such a waste
of taxpayer money really like legalize
the [__] out of it
pay your taxes go buy it have your
diseases tested and have a nice day like
why the [__] am I on the corner here
trying to catch you know the white
collar guy on his lunch break yeah it
just seems mute and how much of it is uh
where there's prostitution there's other
things going on that was that's the for
now the law that's what that's what
that's what they that's what they would
say is it it's a precursor
I don't know if I buy that I would say
that's that's hard for me to wrap my
head around it really is you know I got
a 67 year old man with his wife in the
car no will you [__] us both I'm like
yeah sure no way yeah a 60 or so and
he's hooked up to [__] oxygen at the
time no way yeah I'm like dude I'll kill
you is that
[Music]
the Whopper that's definitely a bucket
list yeah like the 60 70 year old guy
you almost kind of kind of feel like hey
man like what's up with this he's like
hey I'm dying yeah he's probably like
but his wife was with him and what was
she saying does she get in trouble for
that uh they both got arrested yeah
because she solicited it as well yeah
damn I know imagine not even at her age
she's probably like ah [__] it yeah but
still that's kind of crazy all right and
so what's going on with the narcotics
though so the narcotics is a
a lot more dangerous
um do you have a gun now still no gun no
wire okay so when I first started in
Narcotics you have a choice
if you carry a gun and it gets
discovered you're likely going to get
killed 100 percent
if you wear a wire and you get
discovered you're likely going to get
killed so what's your choice it was like
okay [__] it I won't take either so I
never I never carried either
um and you're by yourself or you have
other people with you
um both so we would run in Partners but
I would go into hot crack houses by
myself
he would go into crack houses by himself
when we did Street buys we would just
drive around and Street buy together
um so it's a little bit of Comedy so a
street bar let's just go and uh reverse
here so a street buy you're basically
driving around in a car it's you and
another person in the car uh you're both
police officers and you just pull up
there's somebody standing on the side of
the street they're obvious you can tell
who's dealing and yeah because they're
basically walking but not going anywhere
uh and as you pull up you're just hey
you know I want a baggie of whatever and
they tell you a price you hand them
money and then you guys are arresting
yeah
so we pull we never break our cover yep
we pull off
um if we're doing Street bust then we'll
they'll bust him right there but many
times we'll just continue to buy from
and make a case and when you guys are
doing this is it like you pull off and
they immediately arrest them because
then that kind of tipped them off that
like you were the cops or no uh yeah but
they're selling like Chick-fil-A yeah so
it's it's there's no shortage of buyers
put it that way so sometimes they get it
sometimes they don't but you know it's a
decent sized city and I'm buying all
over the place now are you targeting the
drug dealers or the drug buyers or both
uh dealers the dealers dealers yeah
which again
you know I had this come to Jesus
util it really is this is why I I just
don't believe you're ever going to make
a dent in the drug trade uh it's a waste
of taxpayer money
if these people you know if if you have
people in those economic conditions
they're going to do whatever it takes to
survive I would probably do the same if
I grow up in that in that environment so
if that's what it is then that's what it
is I mean you have a supply and demand
issue you're never going to change that
I just I think it's a waste of taxpayer
dollars and so what should the
government do legalize it all just
legalizing the [__] out of it yeah and
like 50 tax yeah 50 tax like just the
bigger number the better then you're not
going to have the fentanyl issue explain
why because fentanyl is being cut into
different things you know um and by cut
you mean basically uh diluted down using
yeah I'm sorry yeah so for people that
you know if you're buying Coke for all
of you drug addicts you're good you
understand but for everybody else but
here's what yeah exactly here's what cut
means when you're buying Coke it might
not be 100 Coke it's probably got some
fentanyl in it so when you have these
rocket scientists make you know cutting
it with fentanyl they don't know how
much fentanyl is too much I might you
know and that there's a lot of people
dying and they don't even realize
they're taking Fentanyl and that's
probably one of the bigger problems
right now I would agree yeah yeah I
would agree the um uh there's a corridor
in the Northeast where uh for probably
2000s 2010s there was tons and tons of
Percocets and kind of all the the
paintings that was all running through
there
um and now uh there's still some of it
but fentanyl has become the drug of
choice it is uh and it's interesting to
watch the trends change uh but the
problem is you know yes you can overdose
on some of that other stuff but not
nearly as easily as you could
accidentally take some fentanyl oh yeah
just a granule will kill you yeah pretty
crazy do you think China is uh pumping
that into the United States absolutely
and it's a way to kind of eat away at us
from internal mm-hmm
it's pretty smart I mean yeah
unfortunately if it is smart because if
you give Americans a surplus of anything
they will over consume I love talking to
my European friends we're always like yo
big gulp yeah right exactly right right
no we ain't got that yeah everything's
10 times the size right you guys are
savages over here our cars our houses
our drinks our food plates everything is
like 10 times the size yeah yeah but the
human body can still only handle so much
drugs agreed yeah yeah um all right so
when you're doing uh all those drug
busts and everything how much is the
government spending on this stuff a [__]
ton yeah so we have confidential
informants and that's because they get
paid yeah you know at that this was back
in
two thousand so
um my informant was getting
uh we called it a hand-to-hand she was
getting forty dollars per hand to hand
which means
she's literally from the Dealer's hand
to her hand is 40 bucks every time
that's a dealer hands her drugs uh-huh
she's getting 40 in her pocket yep she
was at the end of the day making more
than me yeah she could probably do that
a couple times here in 20 minutes oh God
yeah she just did it
she would go run with us two days a week
eight hour shifts and she was making
double what I was making salary and I'm
like what the [__] that's crazy yeah and
then who sets that price at the time at
the department I guess yeah I have no
idea
in uh
unregistered cash yes unregistered cash
yeah so the cash that we use to buy
deals is always photocopied the serial
numbers are always traced because then
when we bust you and we pull it out of
your pocket we know it you can't say
well I didn't do it yeah yeah yeah yeah
put the unregistered cash you guys would
go to Performance yeah and in cash is
she paying uh income tax on that [__]
come on man come on now so the
government is paying confidential
informants uh cash and then they're not
paying taxes on it yeah maybe if we tax
the confidential informants we could get
the national debt down
or maybe if we don't have to have them
at all
we can get the national debt down I
don't understand maybe we tax the dope
we can get we can uh get the debt down I
mean that probably actually would put a
dent into so it did Issue California is
no longer in debt I mean not California
Colorado I'm sorry is no longer in debt
yeah it's interesting yeah all right and
so when you're doing this at what point
are you like all right I'm done with the
prostitution and the drug dealing
not that you were doing it but yeah yeah
yeah so hey guys what's going on I hope
that you're enjoying this conversation I
wanted to interrupt for a second to tell
you about an event that we're hosting on
March 4th at the Miami Beach Convention
Center it's called lyceum Miami and I've
gone and asked some of the most popular
guests from this show over the years to
come in person at the event it's gonna
be awesome we have everyone from Kathy
Wood to Vivek ramaswamy Chris Williamson
Cody Sanchez and many many others I also
even have a couple of surprises for each
one of you if you show up the best part
about this event is it is completely
free to attend that's right all general
admission tickets are free you simply
need to go to
lyceummiami.com
lyceummiami.com we'll get you free
tickets on March 4th at the Miami Beach
Convention Center and if you're a big
baller and don't just want to get a free
ticket you can also get it VIP or an
Insider pass if you use the code pump 40
you'll get 40 off they get you all kinds
of cool things like the night before a
cocktail with the actual speakers and a
couple other perks go check it all out
at lyceummiami.com and use code pump 40
if you want to be a baller I can't wait
to see all of you there go ahead and
click on the link in the description and
let's get back into this conversation
the drug dealing was
it was one of those come to Jesus
moments where you know um I had some
pretty close calls what was the closest
one
you know I got robbed once
um
I mean that's a gangster right there
robbing the police well they didn't know
I was a police but yeah
um I was swapping out cars almost on
every two or three days just to not
trying to change my parents you know
just
constantly trying because you know once
you work the same area over and over
again
uh you don't want people to get it but
you know I had a gun pulled on me in a
crack house you know when you're walking
into a crack house these people are
desperate and they're all in line
waiting for their Rock what goes on in
the crack house uh they're typically
it's interesting it's like going to the
[__] DMV everybody's just sitting
there looking at each other waiting for
their turn and that's that's the way it
was and the dealer would always go in
the back because they they never want
you to know where they're hiding the
dope but my job was to
act like I'm a dope addict but I'm
literally counting every step that I'm
making if there's stairs I have to count
that amount of stairs I have to remember
if I see a dog if I see children if I
see any fortification whatsoever like
there's like a lot of you know uh visual
memory that I have to do and then I have
to debrief that I'm writing it down as
soon as I get back because once they do
go go bust this you know if I say
you know the door is purple and it was a
[__] duplex and the door was actually
red
that's a big deal you know we just
busted the wrong house and that that is
a big big deal it's a lawsuit I could
lose my job you know there's just a lot
involved in it basically you're doing is
you're Gathering intelligence yeah but
it's so precise how many stairs did I
walk up did the guy have braids did you
know how tall was he how much did you
think he weighed you didn't see where he
got the dope did you see which direction
in the house he went to you know I've
had him pull it out of their gum line
before I've had them pull it out of
their ass literally in their butt cheeks
I've had them pull it out of the freezer
in the ice cube trays I mean you name it
but I have to really remember that while
I'm also paying attention to 12
crackheads next to me trying not to
[__] stab me or Rob me yeah and when
you're doing this uh and you go back and
you debrief I'm assuming it's a SWAT
team or or the DEA or whoever uh are
they then practicing and kind of running
dry runs they do it one dry run so
they'll go by and I have to count how
many houses from the curb it or how many
houses from the uh corner street it was
they'll literally count it verify it
um if they're confused in any way
they'll put me in an unmarked van with
tinted windows and they'll say are you
sure that was the house and I'll be like
yeah you know thank God I never made any
errors
and then uh you're not with them when
they go do the bust no yeah yeah uh far
away were you ever in a crack house when
a bus went down no no so basically you
go in you're getting the uh intelligence
you're getting the drugs you're con you
know
um kind of completing a buy you leave
yeah from there they're dogs chase me
the pit bulls you know from oh man I
mean it's I think a lot of people don't
realize that the generalizations around
crack houses drug dealers you know the
dogs uh where they hide the drugs watch
any movie like at all oh it's [__]
realistic yeah it comes from reality I
mean these TV producers are doing their
due diligence no question there was a
show on a e years ago uh where they
followed the DEA oh yeah it was
fascinating because you know they meet
five six o'clock in the morning right
and they go and they're kicking in
somebody's door and you would watch and
actually one of the uh craziest Parts is
uh you can go find the house you can
usually even find the person find the
drugs in many cases it's very difficult
to do even if you have dogs or whatever
and it reminded me I was in the military
and and before we went to Iraq they gave
us an entire training kind of module on
how to search these homes and so you go
into essentially like a replica home oh
yeah and you're practicing you're
practicing and you're like man I'm a
genius I found this gun I found this
knife I found this whatever you get then
you got like five or six things and
they're like okay come back in with us
uh-huh next thing they bought like 47
weapons oh yeah right they like the
floorboard was uh that's crazy you know
you got to move this thing and hey you
idiots didn't check underneath the table
and all of a sudden you just start to
realize like there was levels to this
and then if you're literally your
freedom and your economic uh earning
ability is predicated on your ability to
hide drugs 100 the money yeah you're
gonna get creative yeah and the thing is
is if you could you know these people
are not dumb if you could put them to
use for something legal and good they're
pretty [__] smart mm-hmm
they really are like they they have come
up with amazing ways to hide dope to try
to
skew the dogs so they can't smell it
what do they do there coffee grounds
yeah motor oil
um you know just wrapping it in
it's it's pretty [__] genius and you
know the mules that they use uh just it
it's ingenious some of the stuff that
they're doing but you know you always
have to stay kind of one step ahead of
them and the only way to do that is with
sea eyes or Undercovers because
basically you have to have the inside
information you have to you have to yeah
and you said that people had them in the
ice cube trays yeah and their butt
cracks and the inside of their mouths
yeah the lip uh where else would they
have the drugs usually
um what's the most common areas it's
just like in a drawer somewhere no so
this was actually pretty pretty good
because you know they always say
possessions nine tenths of the law so
they had to be in possession of the um
narcotics in order to bust them so what
they would do is they would have trash
on the side of the road looks just like
trash they would hide their dope in bags
underneath the trash
so when you came up to buy they don't
have anything on them
once they felt confident with you they
would pull it out of the trash and then
give it to you so if you went to bust
them
they just ran and when if you caught
them they have nothing on their
possession
it's all on the street and you can say I
wasn't mine yeah it was somebody else
stand it out yeah exactly yeah it
um uh it's crazy because I think a lot
of people see the videos that go viral
online yeah of the dirty cops planting
drugs as well and uh obviously it
happens right yes videos of it Etc uh
but it's always these weird things where
you can't let the few bad apples or even
if there's a lot of bad apples ruin the
people who are doing good work but at
the same time to your point the problem
may be so crazy that the entire approach
to trying to solve the problem is wrong
and we have to step back and kind of
think about hey there may be a different
way to address this and it isn't
necessarily kind of in this abrasive
we're gonna rush you we're gonna put you
in a Cell all that it may just be but
we're gonna let you guys do this but we
are going to make it economically
painful I agree you know we've been
doing the same thing for a hundred years
and it's not working like at what point
do we realize this is insanity we need
we need to switch of what we do but also
you know there is a set of rules that we
play by you know law enforcement has a
more stringent set of rules than drug
dealers do but drug dealers even have a
set of rules like it's very taboo for
them to shoot a cop because they know
the Wrath of the world is on them at
that point so you know we have a set of
rules they have a set of rules and
sometimes those rules get crossed and uh
I think on both ends it's the
frustration you know in the law
enforcement it's what what are we
[__] doing here we're just every day
I'm clocking in clocking out and it's
the same people the same amount of drugs
every [__] day and then from the drug
dealer side it's I have no opportunity I
have no education I have no ability to
make enough money to support my family
and they're preventing me from doing
that so I I get both sides yeah it's
pretty crazy
um at what point do you say hey I'm done
being a cop yeah to well uh
2005. was there a specific incident or
it was just kind of you've been doing it
for a while and you want to do something
else yeah it was just kind of that light
bulb moment with narcotics
um and then
I'm like what the [__] like this is you
know uh a glass ceiling it's you're I'm
never I'm just tired of being poor
essentially you know at that point I was
31 years old I have a [__] roommate
I'm like what is this you know and this
is actually an interesting point a lot
of people don't realize uh most cops in
America do not make that much money oh
God I made forty two thousand dollars
after seven years yeah now I make that
in a day yeah it's like what the [__]
well what's crazy about it is I mean
that's basically teachers right very
similar yeah uh a lot of firefighters
right I mean there's a number of these
roles that I think most people would
point out and say like hey that's
important for society they're not
getting paid a lot no I agree and
teachers uh
it's a problem especially in Florida
when you look at what you're getting
paid was that the main driver or things
like getting a pull a gun pulled on you
and that was the main driver yeah it was
just I'm like I can't do this it was
that and it was
why why am I going to continue to do
something that's not making a difference
and put my life on the line for it and
then have to work for idiots in the same
thing it's like man this is just a
trifecta of [__] you know
did the police Chiefs and those folks
that they understand what's happening in
the street or they were too removed oh
[__] no yeah no they're sitting in their
office you know chilling and their
bodyguards and their media and yeah they
don't give a [__] there's a story I hope
I don't get the details wrong but uh
this guy Brian Grazer
um he's a big Hollywood producer uh he
wrote a book
um about uh what he calls curiosity
conversation stuff like 40 years yeah he
would basically call up or write or
whatever just interesting people that he
saw in the news or he heard about or
whatever and he'd be like hey I'm gonna
be in your city or you're coming to LA
or you tell me where to meet you
anywhere in the world but like I would
just like to sit down with you and learn
from you yeah and uh I can't really
offer you that much but like let's have
a conversation because I'm curious about
like you're like yeah and uh the way he
tells the story is I think it was the
day the Rodney King Riot started in La
he had a meeting set that morning with
the LA police chief and he was like for
sure they're canceling this
nope he went to the police station went
up and he spent like 30 minutes or an
hour whatever it was with the police
chief whoa and he was like it was one
thing to talk to the police chief right
it was another thing to talk to him uh
about situation happening outside but it
was like but the most curious part was
seeing what was happening inside that
room while there was chaos outside he
was like it was cool comment collected
wow and so like you hear it and again
you know he's writing this years later
and yeah there's kind of uh the memory
or whatever but like
it's interesting because you you see
this like very different they're very
insulated remembering of the situation
yeah and like if you I'm guessing if you
were to talk to a street cop in La
during those riots they're not cool
common collected right they're dealing
with a whole different situation oh yeah
yeah pretty crazy I think that you know
it's it's all over the media now because
everybody and their mother has a camera
it still happened 20 30 years ago just
nobody had cameras back then you know I
remember we were supposed to take
pictures
of domestic violence
incidents of injuries and I'll never
forget
the department couldn't even afford a
[__] camera
we got grants from domestic violence
organizations that gave us Polaroids
shitty Polaroids that we took pictures
with and that's what we did we had to
hold on to the physical picture and turn
those in as evidence now my
five-year-old has a [__] cell phone
you know what I mean like I didn't even
have that when I was 23. yeah yeah
that's crazy yeah and so when you go to
leave you knew that you wanted to start
uh servicing and cleaning and I started
it before I left okay explain so I asked
the department I said this I've had
switched apartments at the time I went
to this kind of [__] small Mayberry
[__] department and they prevented
us from working off duty I'm like God
talk about insult to injury here you're
paying a [__] and then you're preventing
us from making any more money and why do
they not want you to do that control it
was just systematically control so I
said hey I'm not working off duty in law
enforcement but I want to clean up crime
scenes and they they were like okay well
as long as you don't do it in our city
then it's no conflict you can do it
perfect no problem two months went by
and they're like uh hey we changed our
mind
um it's either the job or the business
and I was like [__] off and I quit
really yep why do you think they changed
their mind control
probably making a lot of money yeah and
so to start off one of these things of
it's okay she uh she seems to be
successful we didn't care exactly we
didn't care when she wanted to you know
sell [__] Blow Pops on the street but
now that she's making real money yeah we
want to curb that got it and so how did
you get started
uh you know I lied to the bank okay and
I uh because they wouldn't give me a
loan and I said that I wanted uh new
windows for my house so I took a home
equity loan of 15 grand
that's all they would give me
so I started out door to door
just going to apartments and hotels and
funeral homes and that's how I got my
first jobs and do you remember the first
one yeah uh
uh first one was a um double homicide on
Christmas day wow yeah
relatives
they killed each other [__] had it
out yeah like a okay Corral yeah in the
house whatever happened to let's go in
the backyard and [__] fight it out oh
no let's pull guns and [__] shoot
each other yeah so uh the mom one of
them hired me and
she's sitting at her kitchen table and
I'm [__] cleaning up the blood from
and you're doing it yeah by myself and
uh there was so much blood that it
leaked into the um
Pantry went through the baseboards the
drywall into the seal plate I'm like
[__] my first job couldn't be
simple yeah no it's got to be horrendous
and when you showed up that first time
you have like hazmat suit on and
everything yeah or yeah yeah so you
pretty much you know what the game yeah
I was trained at that point and I was
ready to go I had all I had the basic
equipment that I could afford with the
15 grand my blood I call it a blood
vacuum to HEPA vacuum personal
protective equipment respirators you
know gloves disinfectant all that [__]
when you say trained like you went to
like a school I went to a school yeah no
they don't do that I went to a private
school it was it's no longer there but
it was a company in uh Dallas Texas got
it so you go and they basically teach
you how to do this yeah they taught me
how to do the actual physical
operational part of it they didn't teach
me any business how do you price this
who's your clients you know that kind of
[__] and when you get there how long
does it take you to clean a double
homicide [__]
well it it took me about two and a half
days
now I could probably do it in about
six hours yeah that's crazy yeah it was
a lot it was I mean two bodies that's a
lot of blood
and as you're doing it like Mom's just
sitting there at the [__] kitchen
table watching me I was like
okay this is [__] weird talk about
feeling like you're under a microscope
but you know after all these years I've
gone through to where some people I
think they find it therapeutic and they
want to watch me clean it up other
people are like I'm [__] leaving call
me when you're done
and that's the majority but you know
I've I had one where Dad was um he had
cancer he didn't want to be a burden to
anybody
he's probably in his 70s so he put a
pillow over his head and shot himself
and the adult daughter hired us so we're
in there you know it's pretty cut and
dry it's on the pillow it's on the The
Mattress
and we're cleaning it up and I find a
piece of his jaw
in the uh on top of the mattress
underneath the pillow and she sees me
she's insisted on watching
she sees me pick it up and before I
could throw it in the red bag
she says
don't do that and I'm like okay she's
like I want it
I'm like I didn't know what to do I was
like what the [__] what do I do
so I was like okay and I give it to her
I come back the next day to finish the
job and she's wearing it around her
[__] neck what's jewelry
her father's jaw yeah
I mean dude I've never been in that
situation so like I feel like I was like
what kind of a [__] yeah is that the
craziest thing that you've seen a family
member do uh that's a [__] up there
let me tell you what are some other ones
uh
uh you know I had a guy once that called
me from Michigan and he said hey my mom
died and he was just [__] real like
playing about it no sadness no nothing
my mom died
um
can you go clean it up
yeah what happened I don't know she
decomposed like God damn okay so I go
over there and I look at it and she had
been there for a [__] long while she
smelled the high heaven down the street
and I was like okay you know it's going
to be whatever amount it was and he's
like oh by the way can you throw
everything away inside the house
I'm like everything he's like yeah and I
go whoa do you want me to save the
pictures and stuff for you like are you
coming down for the funeral oh no we're
gonna have a cremated just throw it all
away I was like what the [__] like some
people are just bam
that's crazy yeah that I felt horrible
because I'm like no wonder the lady
[__] decomposed nobody gave two shits
about her yeah
and when that happens like sad yeah but
also
um
they're there for so long like they just
break down yeah the body just breaks it
does the body does an amazing job of
breaking down quickly you know you start
decomposing 15 minutes after your heart
stops so you know the blood and liquids
and everything is going to go out of
whatever orifice that that it has you
know and the skin just becomes flaccid
and if they're laying on the floor and
the temperature is just not really cold
in the room their Skin's gonna stick to
the floor we've had to pick up their
scalps before because when they remove
the body the whole back of the scalp
stayed attached to the floor so you know
these are not fun not fun yeah yeah not
fun and when you guys go into uh do this
now how many people go in is it like one
person it's never just one yeah two to
three two three two to three for a bio
any more than that and you're like
stepping on each other yeah yeah is it
kind of like Ghostbusters like you show
up and all your equipment you got your
uh yeah yeah and when you're in there
like
okay I get the cleaning part I get the
removal of all the stuff but what are
some of the other components that go
into the job that people may not
understand tons of maggots what does
that mean there's just the maggots you
know everybody is surprised like wait
wait a minute the how did the maggots
get in well all you have to have is one
fly
in there to lay their eggs and then that
creates thousands and thousands of
maggots and uh I like to say that these
maggots are my best employees you know
they're eating up the scene
I don't even have to pay them and they
never call in sick
[Laughter]
so how do you think about the business
now like when someone when you meet
somebody at a coffee shop or something
like ah what do you do oh they [__]
themselves what do you say they're all
you know I it depends any company well
if I'm in the mood to chat
um I'll say you know I'm a crime scene
cleaner and they'll be like what the
[__] what's the craziest thing you ever
saw everybody always knows that yeah
yeah exactly
um if I'm not in the mood to chat I'm
just like oh I own a cleaning company
and they're like ah she's a janitor yeah
yeah whatever you want to think man
yeah exactly
um when you think about this business
is there an opportunity to go and get
the government contracts or it wouldn't
be that uh lucrative so there is but
it's very strategic so certain cities
have the ability to have contracts Miami
happens to be one of them Miami is the
only city in Florida that has the
availability for contract so you have uh
pretty much the entire State of
California surprise surprise has the
ability to have that um and then it's
that sounds like there's zero uh
corruption or other things going on well
as if with everything right yeah so uh
there is it really depends on geography
and you all have built a huge name for
yourself through social media yes which
uh when people think of social media I
think they think of influencers consumer
Brands maybe technology companies
you guys are cleanup crime scenes yeah
uh but you got a million subscribers on
YouTube yeah you have tens of thousands
on Facebook I don't know how many you
have on Instagram or other platforms but
it's a lot yeah
why did you think to go into the
internet from a social media and
marketing perspective so for two reasons
uh the first one was remember when I
first started I everybody thought the
police cleaned it up so I knew I had
that hurdle to overcome and I thought
what is the way to reach the masses
and this was easy it was free and it
gave us the ability to essentially tell
people
police don't do this if you don't hire
it out you're doing it you know it's
it's you as the property owner does it
and number two we got a [__] ton of
inquiries of
this is fascinating like how do you do
this or how do you do that or true crime
like every you know that's kind of the
big thing now so I knew that we would
hit two needs uh just by posting the
videos so we took an educational
approach
where we don't hide anything like you
know nothing's proprietary it's not
[__] rocket scientists right so we're
saying hey this is what we're doing this
is why we're doing it and this is how
we're doing it and it took off
and like are you like hey here's how you
clean a scalp up off a wood floor
totally and you explain like absolutely
the materials you use or whatever
absolutely and are people just like
masochists uh are they just like weirdos
no I think people want to watch people
are enamored with curiosity right you're
always curious about something that you
don't see every day or something wow
that's interesting I had no idea right
and I think people kind of have a morbid
curiosity with what happens to you when
you die do we really even know the
answer to that other than we decompose
and nobody knows what happens after that
so I think there's a huge interest in it
look at the True Crime podcast look at
the most popular shows on TV they're all
either law enforcement or Hospital
related right so people are curious
about it and have you ever had content
taken down off any of the platforms I
think so I think uh Tick Tock is a one
that
their their roles change
um with the wind so uh every once in a
while we will get
um
Community violation or something like
that we'll just remove it what type of
content they don't allow any Gore
whereas the other platforms love Gore
so you really just have to know who your
who your platform is yeah what what is
the definition of Gore like yeah well no
blood no body parts I mean I see the
inflation numbers and that looks gory to
me that's exactly correct yes that
should be a crime to post that like
open opaque definition
I would agree with you there yeah all
right and uh as you as you have been
posting is there a specific type of
content that really takes off with the
audience yes it's typically deaf related
or hoarding hoarding those two are what
we we used to post everything now we're
only posting those two service verticals
okay and what do you do with around
hoarding uh they love to see what people
hoard what becomes Becomes of their
homes
What Becomes of them what are they
hoarding
some animals or animals some hoard trash
this is like they just don't take their
trash out ever
not only do they not take their trash
out they're going to go through your
trash and bring that [__] into their
house
for what purpose because they like it
they're trash people yeah
yeah or they had you know they have
seven vacuums six don't work but I'm
Gonna Keep the six because it has parts
for the one that does work
oh makes sense yeah well of course of
course because the first five don't have
Parts either right man there's some
weird people out there yeah everybody's
got there I thought there should be a
show uh in New York City where they just
shut up people's apartment like surprise
style yeah and they're like MTV Cribs
yeah but like you haven't cleaned
you don't know they're coming and just
like people would be enamored by how
weird [__] people are oh yeah totally
right and just like hey knock knock you
know that would
people would not let them in because the
first time that somebody some camera
crew walked in and was like oh [__]
there's four dildos over there you know
they'd be like oh [__] yeah but but I
think that there's some people who are
super weird who are proud
they want people to know perhaps yeah
like I always just think of uh uh like
the guy who probably has like 16 parrots
yeah he's like come on in look there's
Larry and Rob and yeah Dan right we eat
together we bathe together yeah look I
taught him this trick yeah [__] together
yeah and so you look at it you're like
okay like those types of people would
definitely love it oh yeah and then
there's the people who are doing real
weird stuff yeah yeah I'm good exactly
and then you're like well can we pay you
yeah exactly yeah
I found that people have
um you know they're adamant oh no don't
film me don't feel me but what if we pay
you oh okay yeah come in
so uh you know their threshold changes
when you offer them money do you have to
get approval we do we do we get approval
with everyone and is it just like hey if
you if you uh work with us we're gonna
film yeah it's you know work we could
use this for marketing and educational
purposes and you can say yes or no yeah
will you still do the job if they say no
of course absolutely so basically it's
you ask everyone but some people say no
yeah and do the people who say no ever
have like weird [__] going on
or it's like nah I just I don't wanna
usually if they say no it's it's due to
a suicide interesting yeah they're
they're uh
which you know has always perplexed me
okay that you would feel more
um private about a suicide than you
would about an unattended death
me personally I would be
and this is no shame on anybody else but
I would feel embarrassed
if a family member died unattended
because that would mean that nobody ever
checked on them
whereas a suicide is I view it as a very
personal choice that was the
individual's choice and it's their life
and they can do whatever the [__] they
want with it yeah
um
but most people that decline it's always
a suicide suicide yeah because there's
uh intimacy to it or whatever yeah
absolutely crazy yeah um
what else about the business that people
may not realize that like would be
interesting labor is difficult
other than the physical demands of the
labor yes well you know I think labor in
general in America is is going to [__]
in a hand basket
um
Blue Collar wise and I'm I'm not I'm not
only seeing that with our type of
business but you know I'm hearing it
from plumbers they see people
contractors you name it it's just
it's a change in our work ethic and
everybody wants a [__] ton of money to
do as little as possible and me too yeah
don't we all right but if you don't have
the skill set for that you're not going
to get that yeah I'm joking for those
that are listening or watching
um
and do you think that that is just a
like cultural I think it's cultural yeah
I do I've seen the change since I first
started 18 years ago
um and you know we've actually tested
some different things we've we've tested
paying brand new off the street guy
doesn't even have a high school diploma
15 bucks an hour we've tried paying them
25 an hour all the way up to 35 and we
got the same quality of employee
with three very different pay rates
mm-hmm
what would you say the average employee
you have now college educated High
School educated no high school education
how old are they like high school only
in their 20s High School only in their
20s and so this is something where hey I
don't have tons of options they don't
and so this is a good option because it
probably pays decently well compared to
my other options right uh and I don't
have to have a degree or all this other
stuff but here's the deal they get in
they start working for about 90 days and
they're like okay I know I'm making 20
an hour but this shit's [__] hard I'm
just gonna go to Mickey D's and make 15.
and work just [__] flipping burgers
so I think that's the mentality that's
kind of happened now so
we're really kind of in a conundrum here
of of finding good talent
that's gonna stay how do you do that I
don't know I don't have the secret yet
how often do the employees turn over
about every six months every six months
yeah that's real short yeah it is it's
not near as short as a McDonald's
employee I feel their pain uh but with
ours it's more expensive because you're
giving yeah the training is expensive
the inoculations
um uniforms you know the fit testing and
all that kind of stuff it's expensive
you guys have to do physical fitness
testing uh respirator fit test and the
physical of like an actual physical yeah
you went to play football yeah that's
what I mean it's basically you're
testing the physical uh Fitness or
whatever of the can you breathe with a
respirator on just different like a lot
of people can't do that people don't
know what that is they don't know what
that is yeah it goes through the gas
chamber right yeah
the um uh I I was uh talking to a friend
that was on the show and uh he's a Navy
SEAL there's all this controversy now
about how the seals are getting treated
during their training and as you can
imagine most of the seals are like uh
okay yeah exactly wait till you hear
what happens after yeah
um but uh one of the things that anyone
uh in the army or in the Navy usually
goes through is these gas Chambers and
so uh we're we're joking after the show
that
people think you go into the gas chamber
with the gas mask on no and then you
walk out and like it's just like to test
yeah and we were like if only the public
somehow figured out that no they make
you take the gas mask off talk open your
eyes so you're social your phone number
yeah oh yeah and then they make you put
the gas mask back on and people come out
and they got stuck it's not ringing up
oh yeah and he was like so yeah uh gas
chamber's fine right like like almost if
people actually knew the details they'd
be even more pissed oh yeah but a
respirator you're not necessarily uh
doing that type of stuff but it's very
hard to breathe to your point it is it's
um it's very taxing and you know my
biggest issue with it is well there's
two the cartridges tend to carry a
little bit of weight to them yeah so my
neck at the end of the day is [__] on
fire
um and secondly my peripheral vision is
[__] shot
so when somebody's like you know
swinging a hammer back there I can't see
it I can't see it and you have to wear
the respirator and all the uh protective
equipment because you kind of don't know
what you're you have no idea what's in
there and I don't want you know
hepatitis you know touching my skin you
know C diff MRSA there's just a ton of
[__]
um that you you have to protect yourself
against what's the most fun part of
doing this now you've been doing it for
18 years that it's different every day
what's the worst part
just whatever you just thought you
should say well I I'm thinking I would
say working in confined spaces
like uh claustrophobic yeah I had a guy
that shot himself in the Attic with a
shotgun
and uh
[__] attic Like An Unfinished addict
super small and I'm walking up the
stairs because the the cops were still
there and they're like oh he's up in the
attic you know you can go take a look or
whatever and I get up to the second
floor and his blood is dripping down the
wall on the second floor from the attic
so it looked like The Shining
going in and I'm like oh wow it's fresh
like real fresh and
it's clearly a lot of [__] blood up
there so I go up there and he's still up
there
and
all I could see was about this much of
his scruff
and his face is just blown off his
eyeball is shot into the air vent
and his jaw like just [__] everything
right it's just everywhere and the blood
is just dripping down so not only are
you cleaning the attic now you're
cleaning the [__] second floor which
is a finished living space yeah so it's
it's challenging yeah
um when you think back to the start of
the business what do you wish you knew
that you know now
so much
like I probably lost a [__] ton of money
oh I know I did I lost a [__] ton of
money the first
three years in business because no one
taught me
how do you quote this how do you build
this how do you how do you charge for
this like it was literally just kind of
cowboys and Indians like uh yeah that
sounds good you know and I weigh a way
under charged I was lucky enough to have
an insurance adjuster pull me aside like
three years later and go hey I'm not
supposed to tell you this but you way
under charged I'm like [__] hey are
you serious yeah he's like you should be
charging double wow oh [__] for the same
amount of work yeah yeah that's pretty
crazy yeah because there's just nothing
to go off of it's not like you know
Plumbing I know what a a typical like
truck travel charges or whatever with
this it's totally out of the difference
yeah um I know that you get a lot of
inspiration from other Industries or
other businesses how do you go about
finding those Inspirations or those
ideas that you then can bring into an
industry that frankly there's just not
that many people do or know about
yeah so I I always look outside
Industries and particularly real estate
investment kind of uh for my ideas
especially with marketing so we have to
be kind of strategic about how we market
and um
about five years ago I came up with
bandit signs I'm like man they they do
that everywhere for real estate and it
works so let's try that let's try that
so we kind of deployed that in all of
our markets and we tested kind of
different
type of things well not only did we get
service calls for it we got employees
out of it oh my God crime scene clean I
want to do that are you hiring
like you know people were kind of
enamored with that so I kind of got that
idea from there
um software ideas I get from there to
um you know like crms automation just
things like that there that industry is
very good at that
um
and
we can't do a traditional billboard you
know uh buy one get one free you know
any newspaper ad you can't do anything
like that but radio ad hey if a family
member has passed away yeah if you see
something dripping through your second
floor yeah you can't really do that so
it's been uh a test you know and when I
first started out I did that billboard
thing lost a [__] ton of money because
it never worked but I it was almost like
throwing darts at a dartboard and seeing
what's stuck
um but as I grew I was able to kind of
say okay let's take different Industries
and see what's working for them and see
if that there's a possibility that that
could work with us and social media was
one of those outside of the bank loan
did you have to take any money to grow
the business no yeah well I tried no one
ever gave me any money ain't that a
[__] yeah I tried to get a lot of um
bank loans uh you know things like that
the only thing that I've ever gotten was
a mortgage for our building
and when you look at that is that
actually a blessing in disguise now
not really because I feel like I could
have grown
twice as fast in a shorter period of
time and uh
you know perhaps exited gone into a
different type of industry and you know
just kind of rinse and repeat but I've
been doing this for 18 years that's
that's a bit long yeah my uh my last
question for you yeah are you still
having fun yes I am having fun with uh
various aspects of it you know I I have
a lot of fun with the social media side
of it because I think it's just
it's so ripe for for anything you know
and uh it cracks me up when most
business owners are like oh my God you
have to be so PC you have to watch what
you say watch what you do I'm like [__]
no you don't we do whatever we want we
don't censor [__] if you don't like it
don't [__] watch the channel you know
that's just really what it is and uh
businesses are too focused on being
sterile and we're not
I think that is a great piece of advice
for a lot of people I do cutting through
the noise right if you act talk and uh
kind of conduct yourself the way
everyone else does it's real hard to
stand out absolutely where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find out more about the business well if
you like watching Gore you can go to
YouTube at crime scene cleaning we just
passed a million Subs on that so we're
super excited about that um we're on
Tick Tock as well crime scene cleaning
we got about 5 million there Instagram
Facebook you know we're kind of all over
the place and if we're actually starting
a subscription side on our crime scene
cleaning website crime scenecleaning.com
for
um kind of behind the scenes super gory
videos that we wouldn't make it on on
social
yeah
your own personal gross room right
absolutely and then do you have anything
personally that uh people should follow
yeah I've got a I've got a book getting
ready to come out here uh probably in a
few months we just got signed with an
agent on that so I'm working on that
um we're uh kind of in talks with maybe
a reality show going on here and um
I'm on Facebook as well and you know
LinkedIn and all that other kind of
stuff Laura Spalding awesome well I
appreciate very much I really enjoy this
conversation I learned a lot uh didn't
know the economics of uh Street bus or
or crime scene cleaning but uh what
definitely do this again yeah thanks for
having me